but we got something for you you can do
right now pizza and puppies Pizzeria
Stallone's has teamed up with a local
non-profit potastic friend in an effort
to get more shelter dogs into forever
homes yeah pizza for breakfast what's
the Worst That Could Happen an Italian
restaurant that you just heard about
Stallone just come up with this great
way to help get adoptable pets in front
of customers Candace Charles is live
this morning from the South Valley with
details on how Candace good morning to
you
good morning you guys good morning folks
all you got to do is simply get a
delicious pizza on the box you will see
an awesome flyer for some adoptable dogs
pizzas and pups I mean you can't beat
that it's super cute super fun idea and
I hear that they definitely have a lot
of folks coming through here I'm joined
by Brett Raymer the owner now tell me
how did helpful is something like this
because you guys have a lot of people
coming to right getting pizzas every
week right absolutely yeah we do and uh
it's great because they get to see a
flyer with all these dogs on it and we
just want to bring awareness to the
community and help plautastic friends uh
you know get these dogs adopted now it
smells delicious in here I gotta say
really quickly it smells delicious can
you tell me what's in the sauce and what
you're making right now yeah so we're
making a cheese pizza right now okay uh
just we make our own pizza sauce and uh
we have whole milk mozzarella cheese and
we're using uh some Parmesan cheese and
we're just making something called an
old school which is which is all cheese
pizza awesome awesome one of the
classics you guys can get if you come on
down here I'm gonna try it out for you
really quickly because you know that's
something that I like to do but while
I'm doing so I want to walk over here to
Michael Novelli who is the owner of
politastic friends and has been
partnering of course with this great
Pizzeria as you can see on the box here
this is the flyer how has this helped
you guys out I know you worked with a
lot of pets through these shelters and
there's a lot more in the Sony homes
right there is there's thousands of dogs
here in the Las Vegas community that
need homes we thanks to loans for
letting us promote the dogs that are on
a Richmond training program this is
going to help save a lot of lives and
this is one here you have as well that
you've already trained Zuma so tell us a
little bit about how this process works
and how it helps honestly helps some of
the shelter dogs get into homes and stay
there well it helps change lives because
a lot of these dogs that are living in
shelters there are 24 7. they kind of
get institutionalized when they come to
our Center they learn to socialize they
learn to build confidence they learn to
build trust a lot of these dogs can be
been abused have been abandoned what we
do is a life-changing
opportunity for these dogs to become
better and become the best it could be
we set them up for success and this
right here is helping them be seen and
get adopted so thanks to the loans
this is a life changer for these dogs
Awesome Blossom thank you so much
Michael thanks so much Brett as well you
know I got to eat the pizza for you
really quickly because I've been talking
about pizza all morning I have to eat it
for you
it is good you can come down here and
click a good glass of pizza well maybe
get a new furry friend
well wait a second Candace I know we got
to go but the gas the pizza people to
teach you how to fold the pizza the
right way your whole you can't hold it
like this
one now you know what I'm still a Cali
girl so I'm gonna hold it just like this
I love it